[Music]
tim is with us in uh saint paul
minnesota hi tim welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
so um i'm debt free i've been debt-free
for almost two years i've been i'm 22
years old i have a full-time job
i still live with my parents so i really
don't pay anything
to them for rent or anything i just pay
for my car and my phone insurance
and
i'd like to get out of the house just
with the market kind of things
unreasonable to buy right now and rent
is
outrageously expensive so i guess i'm
just looking for some guidance on what i
should do
okay
how much do you earn
uh i make about 27 an hour
roughly about 50 000 a year i think is
what it comes out to
good for you what do you do
what's that what do you do
i'm a public service worker i work for a
city i'm in public works
okay cool
all right fun fun well my first thought
is you know having been 22 years old and
struggled to get out and figure out how
to make
ends meet when you first move out is
roommates
i mean you can
rent by itself if you're trying to get a
one bedroom apartment that's super
expensive but if you're willing to split
it with somebody else you can really
reduce cost
how do you feel about that would you be
willing to live with other people yeah
yeah and i definitely have you know i
have friends that are just not in the
same position just aren't ready to front
money to move out and so i guess i mean
that's an option that i have looked into
it just hasn't been one that's at the
top of my list i guess
well you make a good income and i mean
you probably could actually afford an
apartment if that's what you really want
um but if you don't have friends that
you know
like in your immediate circle that need
roommates i mean i know for me
i often lived off campus in the summers
and i had times where i had to ask a
friend of a friend or just kind of
coordinate with other people and maybe
not live with all my best friends but i
got to live with people who were decent
enough and made ends meet for me yeah
and they paid the bill and so that's
helpful
um so
tim the way i always look at these
things is on the short term
there's no problem here
but this is a bad long-term plan
it's living in your parents house right
right right exactly and so at some point
we have to uh
we have to launch
now what does that look like and um
rather than just looking at what it
costs today is where do i want to be if
i'm 22 where do i want to be when i'm 30
what i want my life to look like
and what is the best route
to get me there
my personal experience as a dad
is that it will you will have things
develop in you
when you have to buy your own gallon of
milk
and you have to uh fold your own socks
and stuff
and i'm not saying you're lazy
but i'm just saying the when when it
when there's no milk unless you go to
the store and get it
when there's no electricity unless you
keep it on
something happens in your personal
development that is good for you
do i want you to go bankrupt because of
that no i don't but uh when my oldest
came home from college we told her she
could stay for a little while until she
could get situated get her get settled
into the new job and gather up some
roommates and so she stayed with us
about three months and honestly that kid
is an easy kid like you
she wasn't a bother she could have still
be there wouldn't bother us you know but
it wasn't good for her long term and so
we said you know about three months you
need to get you need to get out
and i watched her personality shift a
little when she moved out
i watched her square her shoulders and
throw them back a little bit she walked
a little taller she had a little
different level of dignity and
um
you know easier to get a date when you
don't live with mom and all that kind of
stuff and so you know uh all these
things start to develop
uh and so i i'm gonna recommend as papa
dave
not financial dave that you go ahead and
start looking really aggressively about
getting out it has nothing to do with
math it has everything to do with your
emotional psychological
manhood development and i'm not
panicking about it i'm not calling you a
pansy i'm not any of that i'm just
saying you know it's long term by
christmas if i were in your shoes i
would be out on my own now
uh
that also i think now back to financial
dave i think what i would do is hey i'm
with christina on the roommate thing the
other thing i would do
is i'm gonna shop around because i think
you're a sharp young guy and if you
could find a garage apartment over the
over the top of a garage out back at
some rich old lady's house
and she would just love having tim there
because tim makes her safer because tim
maybe mows the grass or cleans the
gutters i don't know
you might get the deal of the century on
that if you can find it now it's a bit
of a needle in a haystack but it's worth
looking around for and you know talking
to the pastor over at your church and
going hey where's the rich old lady with
the garage apartment i need to talk to
her you know a rich sweet older elderly
lady but whatever you want i don't know
but i mean she's going to like tim
showing up don't you think oh yeah i
think that's a great in-between too
because they're still kind of that homey
comfort where it sounds like he's having
a little bit of a tough time you know
making that transition so it's like
that's a good
i've watched young married couples at 22
do that exact same thing and they get
that rental and it's not you know it's
not the top it's not got the it's you
know not not the resort apartment
complex with 17 pools and bracketball
courts and skylights and jacuzzis right
it's not got all that stuff but who
gives a crap you're just you're getting
started man you're 22. and you know
you're i so that's how i would do it i i
would start figuring out a way to pull
this off there's nothing on fire you're
not a bad person it's not a rush i'm not
saying your parents did something wrong
you did something wrong but you called
and asked and i'm not gonna sit around
wait on rent to get reasonable because
it ain't going to
well that's a great question that's
great that he's calling and he has that
fire in him he's starting to feel that
maybe i don't want to be in the parents
house anymore no it's a good start
some people leave home because they get
thrown out
i mean it's like violent and toxic and
it's not good you know
and so the good news is that tim
actually has wonderful parents and a
wonderful relationship with them so he
doesn't have that pressure
he's not you know because sometimes we
get the call like i gotta get out of
here you know and so it's crazy over
here that kind of stuff and he doesn't
have that thank goodness and my kids
didn't have a lot of that just me
but um
but
but you know i mean so but but roommates
are kind of a standard part of kicking
out there sometimes
sometimes renting something that's not
fancy enough that your friends are
impressed with your rental
by the way that might be a sign if your
friends are impressed with your rental
maybe you got the wrong rental
just a good idea
because it is a rental
yeah that's just something to think
about too if your mom thinks it's
awesome
you might have the wrong one you know
yeah there you go something to think
about tim but again i i
admire you and i appreciate you calling
and i think you'll be a a wonderful
roommate or a wonderful help to the rich
old lady in the garage apartment out